I knew that the train station was
somewhere near and if something is I am
an actor and I have autism it's really
hard for people with any disability to
get a large role in a professional
theatre but for the first time in my
life I'm getting to star in a major
professional production
you said it won't September 12th last
year at first Frank my name is Mickey
row and I am playing Christopher Boone
in the Curious Incident of the dog in
the night-time the Curious Incident of
the dog of the night time is about a boy
who has autism and his adventure that
flips his world upside down I am the
first autistic actor to play Christopher
Boone and I am surprisingly one of the
first autistic actors to play any
autistic character anywhere I've had to
be an actor my whole life to pass as
neurotypical so being an actor comes so
naturally to me I used scripting in my
daily life for example if I went to a
coffee shop I might say to the barista
hi can I please have a medium drip
coffee how's your day going today has it
been busy today and then regardless of
what they say it's been busy or slow I
can then say oh would you like it better
when it's busier when it's slow so that
way I can kind of script my life so I
don't have to deal with social
interactions thank you so much have a
great rest of your day in rehearsal is
my happy spot because I have the lines
I'm playing a character everyone else is
playing a role be it another character
in the player director
during five-minute breaks or 10-minute
breaks or lunch breaks is when you feel
less comfortable you don't have a
specific role during that time which
makes it confusing for someone on the
spectrum on stage there's often bright
light shining on you and loud noises
that come out of nowhere as sound cues
but you've rehearsed all these things in
advance and you know where each sound
cue is happening because it happens in
the exact same place every night so it
almost feels like you're in control of
those things and because you know what
to expect you're in on the magic you
would have to talk to other people
though from Mission Control but we would
do that your radio link up in a TV
monitor it's so rare for any actor with
any disability to get to play a leading
role in any production let alone a
professional traveling production I get
to show people that people with
disabilities we get the job done
[Applause]
[Applause]
akanchha Thomas a Jewish ahora vertebra
Joan la Pucelle Barba a filete Roma
Brosius le top paparazzo preview not no
stipulation real Osceola map el padre de
force a prusik a media la pêche guru
s'appelle lakota trees Schorr labs on
your actual personality Tommy la France
a country serif a risotto
Rubicon polo single a Pascoe
Sania miserable daughter Kathy art such
a planet guru dr. Aldo Moros miss Serena
you promised um Adam Smith chemo also
well there's a municipal measured in a
damp Rock we'd Quahog respect
interpreted and a personage demotius
whiskers interpret a donor gotta be
directly
Garamond jointly oppressor meal of our
presentation Appa Appa Lacroix to
mochila say and I know you too Jules
respect that
Rococo enthusiasm a book Brasilia we
derive a huge fire bridge a double
donation basis upon wha a smoker
[Music]
playing Hamlet has helped me ask
questions of myself that usually I we
very deep inside I never thought I'd do
anything like this to be or not to be
that is the question my name is Leslie
career I'm the founding managing
director of Marin Shakespeare Company
the methodology of our program is
inspired by drama therapy
it creates laughter in the room and it
breaks down barriers between races and
ages and groups it's very beautiful work
and we've seen a lot of transformation
most of the men in the group don't have
any theatre experience and haven't
studied Shakespeare before so when we
start talking about the plays and the
characters they're just bringing their
own personal life experience to the
conversation when I first came in I
thought I would never act again I
attended college back in Nebraska in
1968-69 I was a co major theater and
music when I came into prison there is
this certain demeanor that you have to
establish so in essence I'm acting on a
day-to-day basis just to survive to be
able to be up on that stage letting the
true Steve come through
but in the person of the character
that's the freedom I get or that's what
I hope comes out when I do Polonius
pastoral historical comical this rolous
is so challenging that it makes me go
through the entire gamut of emotions
he's so conflicted that a man I must
have pulled from every facet of my life
I've been betrayed before I've had my
trust broken I've I've done really
horrible things to people you know in a
rage like Hamlet's done well you may see
the inmost part of you over the years
I've learned I have to give back that I
also have to own up and look at what I
did
realistically I'm hoping through other
things that I do my acting I can give
something back to society I've been able
to use all of my past experience and
kind of channel it into this character I
hope that playing my role helps the
other inmates here feel like they're
part of the story this doesn't just help
me escape this helps them escape too it
also helps me a gain a lot of empathy
for you know what other people are going
through it's tearing open old wounds to
try to embody this to bring the
character alive and bring other people
within the story it's
it's difficult but it's also really
cathartic it helps it helps me heal in
this cruel world draw thy breath in pain
to tell my story
the rest
silence
[Applause]
they create worlds from thin air they
tell stories in silence I'm talking of
course about mimes and the man
considered the most famous mime in
history was not only a world-renowned
performer but also save children from
the Nazis during World War two that man
was Marcel Marcel Marceau Marceau is
probably the most iconic image of mime
and that's Shawn when hi she's the
author of a 20 minute silence followed
by applause a book about Marcel's life
the way that we picture mime is someone
who performs without speaking and a lot
of this has to do with Marcel Marceau he
really influenced a lot of our visual
culture Michael Jackson's Moonwalker
after his walking against the wind
he performed up until his death in 2007
and he toured the world over and over
again before his legacy as a mime
Marceau was a young boy in France it was
here he would find his hero in the
movies his inspiration was Charlie
Chaplin his humor his use of physicality
even from a young age Marceau displayed
this kind of like uncanny physical gift
however in May of 1940 Marceau's life
would change forever
MRSA was 16 years old when Germany
marched on France and his childhood
ended all at once Mercer's father died
in Auschwitz and both he and his brother
were very much involved in the war
effort against the Nazis and it was
Marceau skills as a performer that made
him a unique asset there's a story about
Marcel Marceau saving a group of
children from an orphanage he dressed
them up as campers and she would walk
them into safety in Switzerland he was
doing mimicry and he was acting and
essentially he was entertaining them to
the point where they could pretend as if
they were going on vacation rather than
you know fleeing for their lives another
story was that he was encountering a
large group of 30 German soldiers and in
that moment he pretended that he was
actually at the front of a large group
of French soldiers and they actually
surrendered to him it seems as if this
natural knack for acting ended up
becoming a part of his involvement in
the war effort it's been described that
he wasn't just miming because he loved
mime during the war he was miming for
his life
in many ways Marceau's wartime
experience would shape his life's work
he's been his life circling the world
over and over again telling these
stories through his body in a way that
defied language there's something about
that that illness seems like an effort
to bring the world back together doing
something that anyone regardless of
language or nationality can understand
just by looking at him
[Music]
you